[Music]
[Applause]
so that was a 31 QB joke okay hope it's
useful when you doing that trike it's
beatdown
also remember the the moves from both
sides kind of predicated on where your
balance is and what person on the other
side is doing too personally fainting is
just sort of going backwards drilled and
try to put the taxed certain points it
doesn't it doesn't kind of quite work so
if you stop working for you examine what
you're doing I see these they one could
we chose a basic framework that you hang
your moves around and then the moves
should fit with your the way you do move
should fit with the overall scheme of
things okay so that's how I view things
and then selling modify how I move to
fit with the framework of the can we gel
on the car okay
thanks for watching